all right so are you guys doing we are
here today with episode number 15 of
noob with a mill still a little sick at
the beginning of this hopefully I can
get over it throughout this video though
have 134 milk ash a 200 mill bank
overall just 14 episodes we started with
one mill and now we've progressed this
far as far as what I want to do this
episode I now have 86 range 85 mage so I
might try to get to the point where we
can use aura but realistically I want an
abbey demons task or a cave Kraken tasks
cuz I'm 87 Slayer and like a hundred K
into it and haven't gotten either
alright so we're about to finish up a
quest there is sea slug and now I could
finally do this medium clue that I've
had my bank I feel like a noob here we
go
first chest and alright that's not bad
we got a blessing it's cool another
casket a purple sweets 45k we'll take it
and open this now so another clue scroll
inbound and another a tea set add it to
the collection so there we go
another casket great alright so another
medium flew done okay we're gonna go
ahead and get another clue okay whoa
miter and a boater a little bit of
uniques another gasket okay I mean I
guess that's something I can scan people
with and another casket okay well
actually that's a decent amount hell
yeah they like Knight DK from the
teleports will take it and I don't know
what number this is but doesn't matter
to me anymore easy that sucks
oh nice and easy another one and DJ
college that's good boom okay and open
and Ranger boots
nope and bang okay well okay well we got
ourselves another clue scroll alright
alright 14k cash what the hell is that
like rare I don't I don't know what like
I've never hit the cash table before I
don't this and another medium done okay
okay we'll take a page I mean it's not
gonna be worth anything but we'll take
it another medium oh jesus and
[__] me throw kite she'll G whatever
man
and just like that another clue scroll
okay just like that nothing
another casket nice and easy and another
clue oh man we are killing it with the
headband today though we're gonna look
[__] swagged out like look at that
[__] and yeah nothing really to see here
oh I guess I just looked pretty those
look pretty fly I won't lie we're
getting we're getting some hella that
goes good with my top I like it alright
another chest alright another a D and
here we go another so streaming a little
bit but while I was doing those mediums
I did flip some art canes actually so
this arcane I flipped for a good 450k
and then this one I flipped for about
200 so that's a good 650k profit but
yeah other than that not a lot going on
time for another clue okay oh yeah there
we go
full swagged out look at that pimpin we
are pimpin now show you with a D know
now that I had been and there we go
another clue don't Ranger boots okay
well close enough probably like the 25th
[__] medium but nothing but a tea
plates second-to-last medium clear that
I'll be doing and oh my god that's a
short clue there we go
last casket that will be doing 73
nothing much to see here alright well
there we go so I've been merging a
little bit so left the dragon hunter
crossbow for a cool 500k profit we're
trying to sell off the other one for the
same price actually I think a little
higher but you know I'm greedy on top of
that end up selling off 10k mahogany
logs for 42 GP more so that's a 420 K
profit but yeah so oh no we got a mill
pretty much merge another 500k or so
about waiting buying up some eclectic I
don't know I don't know how many I'll
merch I might do some one stream but
yeah got a lot of money hanging around a
little bit of money made so as you guys
can see went ahead and bought the
ancestral row bottom for 10 100 10 mil
250 K solo for pretty much 6-under k
more a little bit of profit there also
sold on to a thousand
drunk cymbals for a 45 GB profit each so
there's another 90 K there 700 K total
don't know if I messed up but we got all
these things but according to the
website GE tracker I can now go ahead
and sell these on for 25 572 not 25 572
okay I'm gonna go ahead and try to do
that hopefully they sell that's 150 3.4
I bought them for 150 2.6 that's gonna
be 800 K profit if we can grab that
apparently I can get more if I wanted to
try to but I'm not - oh I like that I
like that
let's go well so that's an 800 K profit
I'm gonna go ahead and merch another 2
and then we should hit about a mil case
anyone was wondering I did end up
selling off all the tests to go ahead
and show that here in a second so there
they go sold them off for twenty five
five five Oh at least the final three
the other one sold off for 22 k more but
the margin kind of went down a little
bit good one mil profit there on the 8
that we were able to merch in four hours
I mean it took like 10 minutes but yeah
alright first a little bit of post comm
of the episode went ahead and got 86
magic so one of many levels that you
guys see in this video on that 94 grind
from there go ahead and get ourselves a
greater name and sass where I get 97
strength love and a FK greater demons
test which is why I missed the level
because I afk a little too hard then
from there jad test we get so let's go
time for a random a magic level so 87
magic not too bad nothing really to
unlock there but just another magic
level on the way to a 94 back again with
some post con but we go ahead and finish
off our two's our task
obviously gambled the fire cape and
didn't get the pet at any point but what
to do so obviously I'm a little bit of a
Slayer grind here as you guys have seen
of late I've really just been looking
for some ABI demons but we have not been
getting them at all it's tearing me
apart it's just like I haven't gotten a
B demons I haven't gotten Kraken it's
like just give me something man I
haven't I haven't killed anything new
since I don't even know I didn't do any
spiritual mages so obviously not 83 but
as you guys can see just going through a
ton of tasks I have some room dar - that
was flipping I'll talk about that more
once I go back into live come here in a
second but last task without I go ahead
and get before live comp KBD let's do it
and here we are so there was a merge
that I had going on that was a code I
want as you guys can see eighty four
point nine five so I went ahead to made
nine under K off of that and then
earlier I was showing the rune darts I
ended up making about seven hundred K
off these they an insane margin I bought
ten thousand four one two three eight I
sold most of them on four one two eight
six which is about a fifty GP margin and
all them so that's a 500k profit on top
of that I was buying some rune darts P
and then cleaning them I was making
twenty GP off of each of those and get
ten thousand of them so not bad at all
we got a decent amount of money I'm
gonna go ahead and find some more
merchants this is kind of a long-term
thing that I've been doing I bought
these for run 270 ish and so I mean I
went ahead and made 180 K on both of
these so that's a good 360k profit I
just figured there's not very many of
them in the game so their price goes up
and down a lot so I figure I'd
capitalize on that and now we have some
eclectic s-- not a whole lot going on
here clips are so cheap right now and
it's just like at some point they have
to go up and I hope that I'm invested in
them when they do
straight post cotton clip of 88 magic
there we go
alright so it is the morning as you do
and a lot of stuff going on so Ankou top
as you guys can see we went ahead and
sold off for 600 k profit I'll take that
happily we ended up getting 8k rune
darts ish for that price and then we got
another four for this so on average we
bought those for like one two three six
or so so I'm going to go ahead and see
what I can sell those off for mysterious
emblems bought but before I go ahead and
do this I'm gonna see if I can go back I
can so I sold off 250 ish mysterious
emblems 483 K I bought those for 79 so
that's a 1 mil profit right there I had
a feeling they'd go up and they kind of
did last night but I think they've gone
back down a little bit I don't think I'm
gonna lose that much money on them I
don't think I'll lose any money to be
perfectly honest with you I think it's a
pretty good merch since on the day of
release obviously a lot of emblems are
gonna be put into the game but over time
they will slowly go down
because people will stop doing the
Slayer master that's just the way it
works but right now as you guys can see
there's still a 1.7 K margin on them so
I may try it out but apparently I can
sell on the mysterious emblems for eight
one six Oh
which would be a 2 point 6 K profit and
granted given that I have 600 of them
that's going to be around another 1.5
mil that I'll make there I may flip them
a little bit for this one point 6 K
margin but not too bad at all we're
gonna go ahead and now and see what I
can get on these ruined darts all right
so gonna go ahead and use a cleaning
cloth on the rune darts that are
poisoned and as you guys can see a 1 2 7
4 which means I'll be making about about
40 GP on each one which means I mean in
total that's about a 500k profit not too
bad I'm just trying to just try to keep
up on my magic and trying to make money
merging while I do it as you guys can
see I'm over halfway I think 289 I've
just kind of had a lot of homework and
need something Afghan do so merging and
magic has been my meta all right
back again so the mysterious emblems Oh
actually look at this we finally sold
them all off so that's like 170k profit
per one pretty good money made there a
little over a mil that was a pretty long
merch but happy it finally happened so
as you guys can see I went ahead and saw
loss 225 of these mysterious emblems
those are still from the original batch
so these I mean I've already gone over
how much I plan to make off of all these
but you guys have seen that on top of
that though we've bought a lot of
mysterious emblems I'm hoping to merge
for pretty much 80k so as you guys can
see there we got 1,000 almost bought and
we'll go ahead and collect them all as
to 1330 go ahead and see what we can
sell them on for remember I bought a
thousand new 330 or old ones that I had
so
8900 isn't great we'll be making 800
coins per one assuming they all sell but
the problem is you get undercut a lot
with these so we'll see a new time if
they sell but that'd be an 800 k profit
I guess I'll take it I was hoping for
more I know that may sound a bit petty
but trust me when you have this much
money put into them you can't hope for
more at this point to go ahead and get
myself 89 magic so and not too bad
really design
anything obviously on that grind in 94
but go ahead and get ourselves another
test another jad task and I mean I'm not
really about it I don't know why I do
this I go ahead and cancel it I'm an
idiot if you guys ever want to cancel a
jad test just die inside the cave save
yourself points the reason I cancelled
it I mean it's a good task he gives me a
chance at the pet but at the time I was
really looking for afk tasks so I go
ahead and get myself a test from Dara
Dell which may look new but think about
it 250 tests the new thing that they
implement I got 525 points that is
insane that brought us up to like 1.2 K
gives me so much freedom to cancel more
tasks I love it but go ahead and finish
off iron dragon someone get some neck
reels which I eventually cancel all
right well [__] I was just killing some
then just chilling playing a little bit
of rocket League and then I looked down
I saw this I figured someone logged in
under me holy [__] 70 K see it's like a
one and I think mm I've got like 800 KC
on my mane and I haven't gotten it and
oh my god that is great I guess I'm
gonna go to Callisto now because that's
the only reason I was really there it's
one of my favorite pets in the game to
be honest I'm so happy that I just got
it's alright so that pet was pretty high
I'm not gonna lie I'm still pretty hyped
about it but I go ahead and cancel off
his neck real test just because as I
said before I was looking for afk tasks
and then I get myself a jad task I'm
like [__] kill me so I ended up dying
to that we ought ourselves some tags I
was a happy man
go ahead and get ourselves another
[__] jad task man okay so last night
before I went to bed I tried to buy a
bludgeon for 5% above and it didn't buy
and I'm like okay well we're gonna go
ahead and make some profit off of this
so as you guys can see here I went ahead
and merged bludgeon last night for one
milk another one for a mil and another
one for 900 K so 2.9 Mellet there our
mysterious emblem merch is looking
pretty poor right now basically as you
guys can well you guys can't see I guess
but we have a 1.2 thousand of them I
bought them for about 80 K I still think
that they can go up I don't think that
many people are actually going to be
doing this wilderness slay and I think
the emblems are just coming in the game
rather quickly off that I would imagine
and I think that this is just a
a quick reaction by the economy but
they've gone down even more they're down
to 71 which means I will lose 10 mil off
of this merch which is killing me man I
don't know how far they could drop and I
don't want to panic sell them now
because if I sell them now I'm falling
into the trap that everyone else is
falling into which is just sell they
sell they sell these no one knows how
much these things are actually going to
come in the game off wilderness Slayer
Wilner Slayer will be obsolete I would
imagine
no one I mean the only reason you do is
4 point boosting which for any regular
Slayer you don't need it's only people
are going for a slayer helm so I think
over time people have come to their
senses and these things should go up but
I can also cut through this clip here in
[__] 5 episodes and they're 40k who
knows and that'll be it for this video
so basically I haven't recorded anything
in a little while I'm kind of dropping
frames a little bit right here but what
I've been up to is pretty much magic I
got 90 just a little bit ago I also have
been working on agility about to get 63
the main reasons I'm working on agility
is because as you guys know we haven't
seen any Zoeller yet and that's the best
moneymaker in the game so oh hey what's
going on my man I'm gonna finish this
out rather than talk to him but so Zola
is the best moneymaker in the game I
haven't done it yet and so I'm gonna
have to go ahead and do that after all
these years I've only been on YouTube
for like a year but anyways so I haven't
done any Zola I think I have to get 71
agility and then I'll be able to do it
so I'm hoping that we can get up there
it's gonna be a grind I hate agility but
I do also need the full graceful set so
that's what I've been up to I'm gonna go
ahead and now and get the bank value for
this episode so give me one second and I
have five mil in the grand exchange just
in items so go ahead and take that into
account but calculate 216 mil in the
bank I take that all back that's not 216
mil I thought it was I was happy about
it then I realized
mysterious emblems not worth a hundred
seventeen mil like I had thought that's
disappointing conduit your piece of [__]
I hope you know that all right so while
conduit says that they are 117 mill I'm
gonna go ahead and show you guys what
they are right now so we multiply this
time 75 oh I guess we can do that and
then subtract one two one two there are
actually only 91 mill so take go ahead
and take off what 20:27 mill of their
estimate or 20:26 mill off of this so
we're actually at 195 mill which makes a
little bit more sense because I just
I've been spending money to go ahead and
get this magic level up like it makes
sense to me that this is happening right
now but I'm really disappointed because
I actually thought we made a ton of
money this episode we did not but we
have made a lot of progress and that's
what really counts so as far as those
over grind goes once we can get there
the money will start pouring in the
merchants start going everything will be
good can promise you that so tomorrow
I'll be releasing a video on the whip
versus the ArcLight so you guys want to
see that make sure it's sub button if
you guys enjoy my content anyways feel
free this up button shows me a little
bit of support you guys enjoyed the
video make sure to leave a like anything
you guys want to tell me about go ahead
and comment about it down below and yeah
Twitter in the description but with that
said though I hope you guys have